Let me ask you something.
You and I have both worked
at "Saturday Night Live."
Oh, we're going to--
And I am curious--
(J.B. laughing)
'Cause everyone tells me,
when I was at "Saturday Night Live,"
I wasn't one of those quiet writers.
I liked to sort of get up and
perform my ideas for people.
I was the guy that was always talking,
and I've heard that you were the same way,
that you liked to, when you had an idea,
and you wanted to make a comedy pitch,
that you could make
everybody in the room laugh.
Is that true?
Yeah, man, 'cause you know what?
We had that stand-up mentality.
Now, some people came
in the show, of course,
as straight writers, and some
came in as stand-up artists.
We are used to being in
front of an audience.
We're used to projecting a certain way,
and we like to paint pictures
of what we're pitching.
So that was my style.
You know what I love to hear about is
I love to hear about the
ideas that never made it
onto "Saturday Night Live."
Whoo hoo!
Those are my favorite ideas.
Do you have any pitches that you did--
Oh!
Back in the day that you loved,
and you got up, and you performed them,
and it never got on the show?
Oh yeah, man.
I had a bunch of them, man.
I had one.
This one I love.
This one I don't understand
why it didn't make it,
but this is one of my favorite ones.
So, I had a guy that
used to work in a bank.
[Conan] Used to work in a bank.
He was a bank teller for years,
years, doing bank teller.
When you work somewhere, you
start to take on your job.
Your job becomes a part of you
'cause you go there every day.
You're doing it every day.
He's a bank teller.
When you count money, you lick the thumb.
Lick your thumb, and
you count the money out.
[Conan] Right.
This is a person that's good,
if you don't have one of those
little round circle sponges
that you put your thumb in.
[Conan] Yeah.
But anyway, most people are
so used to counting money,
they lick their thumb--
Yeah, I do that, yeah.
And they count that money for you,
lay that money all out for you, right?
So this guy ends up getting
fired, right, from the bank.
He moved on.
He was there for a long time.
He ends up getting a new job.
Now he works at a sandwich shop.
Now, but he's working at a sandwich shop,
like Subway or something like that,
but he can't get the bank
teller out of his system.
So he's making you a sandwich.
You want the club sandwich.
You know the club sandwich
comes with the bacon,
comes with the turkey, the Swiss.
You want that, right?
And he asks you if you
want Swiss cheese on it,
and he licks his finger
(Conan laughing)
and puts that cheese on it
every time, every single time.
"You want to add salami?"
And then, lick the thumb, every time,
every time he's putting the meat on,
which is disgusting.
Uh huh.
But he can't stop.
(Conan laughing)
He can't stop doing it.
I love that idea.
That didn't get on the air?
That idea should have made it.
Licking your thumb, making
a sandwich for somebody,
that should have made it.
Yeah.
That should have made it.
What else? You got another one?
I want to hear another one.
Oh, oh, oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got a few of them, man.
I got one.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
This one right here never made it.
This was Tom Brady, the
quarterback Tom Brady
who used to play for the Patriots,
who now plays for the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers.
This guy, he was a guest on the show.
[Conan] He was the guest host.
He was the guest host,
and he came to the show,
and I wrote this idea for him
where he was the first player in the NFL
to smack another man on
the butt after a good play.
Oh, man, but it was a
throwback back to the '40s.
Yeah.
Back in the days when
guys wore leather helmets.
Yeah, yeah.
And he just kept smacking guys on the ass
after a good play, spanking on the ass,
uhn, spanking on the
ass after a good play.
But nobody understood why
this guy was doing this
for a long time.
(Conan laughing)
Why does this guy keep doing this?
Why does he keep smacking
people on the butt?
Nobody understood why he kept doing it,
so he was the only NFL player in the world
who got traded to every team in the NFL
(Conan laughing)
'cause no one understood
what the hell he was doing.
And when he started
doing it in the shower,
that's when it went up to another level.
Yeah, yeah.
That's a very funny idea.
I can't believe, I think
that's a good sketch.
Oh, that's a great sketch idea.
You kidding me?
There's a million of them
that should have made it,
and I just don't, but
you know, I digress, man.
It's all good.
Well, you don't care.
They didn't get on the
show, but look at you now.
You're in your zen space.
In my zen space.
You're happy.
(J.B. laughing)